foreign
[Music]
briefing for Thursday October 13th I'm
Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
if your job involves responding to
crises you might expect to work nights
weekends holidays and that's been the
situation for many cyber security
incident responders
as the number of hacks worldwide has
gone up so is their workload to a point
where according to a recent survey from
IBM over two-thirds of these workers
report being assigned two or more
incidents to respond to at once so what
does all this mean for an industry
that's crucial to protecting modern
businesses and how can companies protect
these overstretched workers joining us
to discuss that is wsj pro cyber
security reporter James Rundle hi James
hi sorry how you doing I'm doing great I
wonder if you can start by kind of
giving us a sense of the way work has
changed for the cyber security
professionals over you know just the
last few years yeah there's been a
significant change for every type of
cyber security professional but
particularly incident responders
obviously
cyber attacks have grown significantly
in the past few years both as a result
of the world becoming more networked
particularly during the pandemic but
also advances in technology on on the
part of the criminals as well so
really they're finding themselves
dealing with a massive influx of attacks
against companies of all stripes on all
sizes government agencies public bodies
and coming from all angles as well
criminals nation states and everything
in between from the people that you
spoke with I mean what kinds of symptoms
of overwork or stress did they describe
having to deal with what was their day
like overloaded I think in a word from a
lot of people I spoke to a lot of people
are working multiple jobs simultaneously
and that's a change from the past few
years as well you know previously this
was a job where you would go in person
to a company when it was attacked so
you'd be on site for days or even weeks
at a time so you can only focus on one
client with the pandemic that meant
everyone obviously was working from home
so for instance responders it meant they
could juggle more jobs at the same time
I spoke to one person who said that he
would sign on in a zoom call for one job
first thing in the morning move on to
the next one move on to the next one
then throughout the day just shift
between them as necessary it's been a
significant increase in their workload
and that comes with what you would
expect from that as well the symptoms of
burnout a lot of them described a lot of
them feel anxiety
some say that it's affecting their
personal lives IBM did some research
specifically around this area and they
said that around two-thirds of people
they surveyed said they'd sought some
kind of assistance for their mental
well-being recently just due to the
level of work and the stress that's
involved in that work as well what can
the companies do from their perspective
to help address this problem because it
doesn't sound like the incidence of of
cyber attacks are really going away
they're not and companies are aware of
this I have to say everyone I spoke to
in a senior role for the story was
acutely aware of the stress that their
employees were under because they've
done it themselves I mean this isn't a
career where you kind of go in at the
senior level without working in the
trenches so they've experienced it and
they understand that there are immense
pressures on their on their employees I
spoke to one fellow at salesforces so
that they give one Friday a month off
just for mental well-being for their
employees a lot of them have rules about
how many engagements their instant
responders can work on back to back at
IBM for instance no more than to and a
lot of them talked about just
communicating with the staff checking in
with them making sure that they are
taking care of themselves that they are
managing their stress properly and you
know some things are unavoidable in this
job cyber attacks generally happen on
holidays they happen on weekends at
inconvenient times and these guys are
expected to respond but for a lot of
them they just said it's a balancing act
and I think from the instant responders
perspective that IBM researcher
mentioned around well over three
quarters said that they felt supported
by their company which is a positive
sign I mean that that does at least
sound really positive I wonder though is
this something where the companies that
are being attacked should have been
putting in more cyber defenses so that
we don't see as many incidents needing
to be responded to I 100 uh and that was
a Common Thread from people I spoke to
about this work they just said they go
in to respond to these incidents and
often the work they have to do is
Complicated by the fact that the company
didn't have basic Protections in place
and this is a line you keep being
repeated by the Department of Homeland
Security by the Federal Bureau of
Investigation by anyone who really
responds to this saying that if you do
put basic Protections in place and you
make the effort now then it will
honestly prevents a lot of cyber attacks
and then if it doesn't then at least
reduce the time taken to recover and it
will also reduce the burden on your
instant responders and the cost to you
as well I mean a lot of them said that
at their engagements the first thing
they often have to do is an education
exercise to explain just what has been
going on to Executives who don't know
about cyber security
so let's talk about this problem then
moving forward is there a way apart from
beefing up their own cyber security that
companies can deal with this to help
prevent the burnout from happening in
the first place I think so what are the
main problems really is a lack of people
who are available to do these jobs the
the talent shortage in cyber security
has been pretty well documented by us
and others you know depending on what
statistics you look at there are over
800 000 unfilled positions in the US
right now over 2 million worldwide so a
lot of effort has to go into building
this pipeline of professionals who can
come in who can staff up these companies
so you're not just relying on a group of
people just to do you know increasing
amounts of work all the time and there
are efforts underway the White House
held a summit earlier this year on ways
in which the workforce can be developed
a lot of private companies are putting
initiatives in place to partner with
universities with schools and to train
internally to try and get these numbers
up and make sure that we have a
competitive stable and continuing
Workforce that we can grow all right
that was the wsg cyber security reporter
James Rundle thanks for breaking this
down for us James no problem
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories check out
our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]